Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En 1990, el gobierno de Italia
contrató a los mejores ingenieros
para que enderezaran
la famosa Torre inclinada de Pisa.
Hubo numerosos intentos de enderezar
la torre en sus 800 años de existencia,
pero los modelos digitales de este equipo
revelaron la urgencia de la situación.
Predecían que la torre se caería
si alcanzaba un ángulo de 5,44 grados...
se encontraba en ese momento a 5,5 grados.
Nadie entendía cómo la torre aún
se sostenía, pero la crisis era evidente:
debían resolver un problema que había
pasmado a los ingenieros durante siglos,
y debían hacerlo con rapidez.
Para comprender esta situación,
es necesario entender por qué
la torre se inclinó en primer lugar.
En el siglo XII, la república
marítima y acaudalada de Pisa
se dispuso a convertir sus catedrales
en obras magníficas.
Los obreros embellecieron
y expandieron las iglesias existentes
y agregaron un enorme baptisterio
con domo a la plaza.
En 1173, comenzó la construcción
de un campanil o campanario.
Los ingenieros y arquitectos de la época
eran expertos en sus oficios,
pero a pesar de todo
su conocimiento en ingeniería,
sabían poco sobre el suelo
en que se sostenía la torre.
El nombre "Pisa" proviene de una palabra
griega que significa "suelo pantanoso",
lo que describe a la perfección
la arcilla, el lodo y la arena húmeda
bajo la superficie de la ciudad.
Los romanos en la Antigüedad
contrarrestaban condiciones similares
con enormes pilares de piedra,
llamados "pilotes", que se enterraban
en la estable base rocosa de la Tierra.
Sin embargo,
los arquitectos de la torre pensaron que
unos cimientos de 3 m serían suficientes
para sostener la estructura
que era relativamente baja.
Desafortunadamente para ellos,
unos cuatro años más tarde,
el lado sur de la torre
estaba ya bajo tierra.
Hacer cambios en los cimientos
hubiese sido, normalmente, un error fatal.
Si se agregaba más peso,
la presión de los pisos superiores
hundiría la estructura
y aumentaría la inclinación
de forma peligrosa.
Pero la construcción se detuvo
en el piso cuarto por casi un siglo,
pues Pisa se sumió
en una prolongada guerra.
Esta extendida pausa
permitió que el suelo se asentara,
y cuando la construcción
se reanudó en el año 1272,
los cimientos descansaban
sobre suelo un poco más estable.
Bajo la dirección del arquitecto
Giovanni di Simone,
los obreros compensaron
la leve inclinación de la torre
por medio de pisos
más altos sobre el lado sur.
Pero el peso de la construcción extra
hizo que ese lado se hundiera más aún.
Cuando completaron
el piso séptimo y el campanario,
el ángulo de inclinación
era de 1,6 grados.
Durante siglos,
los ingenieros implementaron
varias estrategias para solucionar esto.
En 1838,
cavaron un pasadizo alrededor de la base
para examinar los cimientos hundidos.
Pero el remover la arena de apoyo
solamente empeoró la inclinación.
En 1935,
el Cuerpo italiano de Ingenieros inyectó
argamasa en la base para fortalecerla.
Sin embargo, no fue distribuida
uniformemente por los cimientos
y esto provocó otra inclinación repentina.
Todos estos intentos fallidos
sumados a los cimientos inestables
hicieron que la torre se acercara
cada vez más a su límite.
Y sin el conocimiento definitivo
sobre la composición del suelo,
los ingenieros no podían localizar
el ángulo fatal de la torre
ni idear un dispositivo
que evitara su caída.
Tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
los investigadores idearon pruebas para
identificar esas variables desconocidas.
En 1970, los ingenieros calcularon
el centro de gravedad de la torre.
Contando con esta información
y con nueva capacidad de cómputo,
los ingenieros pudieron
determinar la dureza del suelo,
la trayectoria de la torre
y cuánto debían escavar exactamente
para que la torre se mantuviera de pie.
En 1992, el equipo excavó
túneles diagonales
para extraer 38 m cúbicos de tierra
de abajo de la torre en el lado norte.
Luego, colocaron un contrapeso temporal
de 600 toneladas de lingotes de plomo.
Por último, anclaron
la base con cables de acero.
Más de seis siglos
posteriores a su construcción,
la torre fue finalmente enderezada
a un ángulo de unos cuatro grados.
Nadie quería que la torre cayera,
pero tampoco querían perder
la atracción más famosa de la zona.
Actualmente, la torre
tiene unos 55 o 56 m de altura.
Seguramente continuará
estable por al menos 300 años
como monumento a la belleza
de la imperfección.